es geht um dieses ding und um einen
handfesten
manipulationsskandal beim öffentlich
rechtlichen fernsehen beim
mitteldeutschen rundfunk dazu bei uns im
studio bild chef julian reichelt müssen
uns kurz erklären dass hier das ist ein
mikrofon pop schutz den ich gerade in
die kamera gehalten habe so was kennen
wir von allen möglichen reporter
einsätzen auch von uns und der mdr
wollte das ding mit dem bild logo
explizit nicht im bild haben es war nun
mal da aber man hat anschließend einfach
aus dem bild gelöscht ja wir sehen da
ein presse statement der dresdner
staatsanwaltschaft ist es glaube ich
wenn man sieht auf den bildern ganz
eindeutig dass unser reporter da war und
dass unser reporter unserer mikrofon mit
unserem logo in die kamera gehalten hat
und das hat den öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk offenbar nicht gepasst wir
erinnern uns dem öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk für den wir alle gezwungen sind
zu bezahlen um ausgewogene wahre echte
informationen zu haben dieser öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunk verfälscht und
verändert die wahrheit weil er es den
kollegen wenn man das noch so sagen kann
denn eigentlich wer so etwas macht ist
entfernt sich aus dem journalismus weil
es den herrschaften dort offenbar nicht
passt dass es bild gibt das ist ein
handfester skandal skandal denn es
besteht eben genau der auftrag an den
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk so zu
informieren deswegen bezahlen wir dafür
wie die wirklichkeit ist ich habe hier
ein spannendes zitat gefunden von der
chefin des mitteldeutschen rundfunks
frau wille das ist nicht mal einen monat
alt und bezieht sich auf das
verfassungsgerichtsurteil warum es
sinnvoll und gut ist dass wir noch mehr
gebühren für diesen fälschungs
journalismus bezahlen da hat sie gesagt
das verfassungsgericht hat die relevanz
des öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunks
gestärkt und betont dass seine bedeutung
für seine vielfalt sichern
orientierungshilfe in zeiten von filter
blasen fake news und desinformationen
noch wachsen die wahrheit ist wir haben
es hier wiesen der mitteldeutsche
rundfunk hat es zugegeben es ist nicht
eine ein öffentlich rechtlicher rundfunk
gegen desinformation es ist ein
öffentlich rechtlicher rundfunk der
desinformation
denn wer die wirklichkeit ja ganz
offenkundig ideologischen gründen fällt
der öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk ist
der rundfunk der bild offenbar nicht mag
der bild tilgen auslöschen weg löschen
ein solcher öffentlich rechtlicher
rundfunk kann ja keinen auftrag haben
uns zu informieren wenn das was da
einfach nicht ins weltbild passt
gelöscht wird und deswegen muss man es
sagen gibt es uns unter anderem damit es
eine
informationsquelle gibt die eben nicht
so ideologisch vorgeht wie dort
ideologisch auf unsägliche weise
vorgegangen wird jetzt die
entschuldigungen julian es hier auch
noch mal genauer anschauen einen
mitarbeiter hat aus ästhetischen gründen
soll heißt es so entschieden und weiter
ist es in den zitat wir bitten um
entschuldigung leider müssen wir
bestätigen dass das mikrofon in diesem
beitrag verfremdet worden ist der
entsprechende beitrag wird auf unseren
websites und in der mediathek
unverzüglich korrigiert und wir werden
uns auch heute abend im enden der
sachsenspiegel für dieses fehlverhalten
entschuldigen korrigiert bedeutet wir in
dem fall zum original zurückgenommen
also zurück genommen also korrigieren
heißt beim öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunk zu weit zurück kennen und auch
die begründung aus ästhetischen gründen
ist natürlich eher furchterregend aus
ästhetischen gründen heißt hier das eine
marke die den herrschaften dort nicht
ins weltbild passt die den herrschaften
dort nicht genehm ist sozusagen
vorsorglich aus ästhetischen gründen
einfach gestrichen wird unsichtbar
gemacht wird aus der realität entfernt
wird und dass man muss es immer wieder
sagen ist etwas wofür wir bezahlen dass
dort menschen entscheiden ihm passt
etwas nicht in ihr weltbild und deswegen
finden sie es unästhetisch weil sie
politisch anderer meinung sind weil sie
unsere berichterstattung an manchen
punkt mich mögen das empfinden sie als
unästhetisch und deswegen empfinden sie
es als legitim
hier wird ja auch nicht so wirklich
gesagt wofür man sich da eigentlich
entschuldigt und warum man das
eigentlich gemacht hat ästhetisch ist ja
nichts anderes als das nächste
täuschungsmanöver da wird in der
erklärung für einen solchen skandal
schon wieder gelogen natürlich ist das
nicht aus ästhetischen sondern aus
politischen gründen geschehen man kann
es nur sagen dort werden menschen für
die gebühren die sie gezwungen sind zu
bezahlen einfach getäuscht und belogen
wir haben das am gestrigen abend dann
erfahren unser kollege philipp iad die
fotos die gegenüberstellung original und
sachsenspiegel auch veröffentlicht bei
twitter wir haben dann hier in der
redaktion aber ganz genau geschaut kann
das überhaupt sein wir wollten es erst
nicht glauben mensch das da bild
wegretuschiert wurde haben uns den
kopfschutz noch mal vorgenommen auch in
die kamera gehalten sie können hier noch
mal ganz kurz schauen und wir dachten
weil auch entsprechende twitter
kommentare kam mensch das ist nur
verdreht aber sie können es drehen und
wenden es bleibt immer bei bild bei
diesem pop schutz den unsere kollegen
dort gestern in dresden bei dem
statement der staatsanwaltschaft zum
fall raubüberfall grünes gewölbe der
gestern benutzt haben also wie gesagt
man kriegt bild in dem fall nicht weg
außer eben mit technischen hilfsmitteln
im digitalen schnitt in der schnitt
kammer beim mitteldeutschen rundfunk
also das ist eine gewisse mühe dann auch
da tatsächlich es ist ein das
unkenntlich es ist eine enorme mühe das
muss man unseren zusammen und zu schauen
vielleicht auch mal sagen wer das macht
ist überzeugt davon und betreibt enormen
aufwand dafür dass er dort ideologisch
irgendwie im recht ist dass es in
irgendeiner weise gerechtfertigt oder
angemessen wäre deutschlands größte
medienmarke aus berichterstattung heraus
zu tilgen wie gesagt das hat nichts mit
ästhetik sondern mit politisch zutiefst
verstörenden überteuerung zu tun und da
muss in den nächsten tagen und wochen
politisch die frage gestellt werden
sollen wir für die politische
überzeugung dass die wahrheit verändert
und gefällt gehört je nach eigenem
weltbild sollen wir dafür wirklich
gezwungen sein zu bezahlen hat das
wirklich was damit zu tun was die chefin
des mitteldeutschen rundfunks gesagt hat
das es fake news vorbeugend ein es beugt
fake news nicht vor es ist fake news es
ist eine fälschlich hergestellte
wirklichkeit die mit der realität nichts
zu tun hat das ist das was man dort für
gebühren bekommt und es ist ja auch
nicht das erste mal dass inhalte
manipuliert wurden das macht das mit dem
vertrauen der menschen was macht das mit
den menschen die einschalten und der
festen überzeugung sind hier bekomme ich
die wahrheit abgewählt also gerade der
mitteldeutsche rundfunk steht ja in
einer gewissen tradition
er sendet im osten dieses landes in dem
die medien
jahrzehntelang nicht frei wann das merkt
man dem mitteldeutschen rundfunk finde
ich sehr oft an der mitteldeutsche
rundfunk hat eine besondere nähe
besondere zuneigung merkt man immer
wieder in beiträgen zu russland zum
beispiel zu der propaganda die dort aus
russland immer wieder kommt das merkt
man in vielen beiträgen immer sehr sehr
deutlich und offenbar sehen sich einige
mitarbeiter des mitteldeutschen
rundfunks immer noch in der tradition
dass man
nicht im journalismus sondern in dieser
form von propaganda einfach verschweigen
löschen tilgen kann was ins weltbild
nicht hineinpasst ist auch vollkommen ok
macht russia today auch nur dafür sind
wir nicht gezogen zu bezahlen jetzt ist
es mit der entschuldigung noch nicht
ganz getan denn dieser fall ist nicht
aufgeklärt es bleibt weiter im raum
stehen was ist das eigentlich mit der
ästhetik was da schiefgelaufen ist und
du sagst schon das kann keine
ästhetische gründe gehabt haben aber vor
allen dingen steht die frage im raum ist
das ein einzelner redakteur alle
beiträge werden abgenommen von einem
chef vom dienst bei so einer wichtigen
sendung auch wahrscheinlich noch in
höheren ebenen es handelt sich hier um
deutschlands berühmteste und größte
medienmarke das logo von bild kennt
glaube ich jeder in diesem land und es
fällt auch jedem relativ leicht auf dass
da doch irgendwas fehlt auf diese mikro
in abnahme prozessen dabei handelt es
sich ja nicht um einen um die
ästhetischen vorstellungen irgendeines
niedrig reinigen mitarbeiters der da
gesagt hat auch das sieht das bild ist
doch viel schöner wenn er diese vier
weißen buchstaben darauf fehlen dafür
muss ein klima bestehen für solche
fälschungs vorgänger das ist ein
hochkomplexer fälschungs vorgang man
muss durch eine ganze filmsequenz frame
by frame also bild für bild 100 sekunde
für hundertstelsekunde durchgehen und
das überall ausradieren so etwas
passiert nur wenn das immer besteht und
da geht es direkt an die
sendeverantwortlichen die inhaltlich
verantwortlichen nicht an den einzelnen
bildbearbeiter so was geschieht nur wenn
ein klima besteht dass es vollkommen in
ordnung ist und es ist nicht der erste
fall beim mdr die fältchen auch gerne
mal aus demonstrationen irgendwelche
plakat heraus die ihn nicht ins weltbild
passen ist nicht das erste mal dafür
muss ein klima bestehen und dieses klima
gehört politisch aufgearbeitet da muss
es kontrollinstanzen geben die jetzt
hinterfragen wer ist an der spitze für
verantwortlich dass es ein klima gibt
bei denen bei dem rundfunk für den wir
gezwungen sind zu bezahlen dass die
realität auf diese weise gefälscht wird
ein unglaublicher fall julian reichelt
hier bei uns im studio zu besuchen
herzlichen dank
[Musik]